c'est un grand vin décembre que le
département va célébrer au musée
historique de villèle et dans toutes les
mines parce qu'ils donnent le coup
d'envoi d'un grand projet pour le musée
appelé à devenir le musée de
l'habitation et de l' esclavage et parce
qu'il donne le départ d'une année
entière de commémoration nous allons
rassembler ici d'abord bien sûr des
enfants de nos écoles de nos collèges de
nos lycées mais aussi le monde sportif
le monde culturel le monde scientifique
toutes ces personnes réunies pour mener
à bien vos projets le projet grand musée
de villèle c'est ce que nous voulons
parce que bien sûr il s'agit de
commémorer durant quelques jours mais
nous devons nous projeter sur l'avenir
éclairer l'avenir et ce site sera le
lieu de mémoire
mais le lieu où on offrira aussi à
l'ensemble des réunionnais va des
espaces pour réfléchir réfléchir à ce
que nous devons faire pour nos
générations futures ou leur a compris
cette commémoration n'est pas seulement
un temps de recueillement est un rendez
vous festif
elle s'inscrit dans le long terme dans
une volonté assumée d'enrichir et de
partager avec tous les réunionnais les
savoirs sur l' esclavage et aussi les
héritages qui l'a laissée à la société
réunionnaise pour partager les savoirs
les supports sont innovants une
application mobile qui connaît propose
pour son lancement un quiz thématique de
170 questions à destination de tous les
publics
téléchargeable gratuitement l on
proposera bien davantage dès 2019 et
s'élargira à l'histoire de l'exclavage
dans le monde alors que le site internet
du musée de villèle
elle refait et évoluera encore avec le
chantier en deuxième site inédit est
attendue sera totalement consacré à
l'histoire et aux mémoires de
l'esclavagé à la réunion sa partie
scientifique bénéficie de la
contribution de 28 experts
historiens anthropologues archéologues
le site propose des images anciennes des
bibliographies une filmographie on
trouvera notamment des documentaires
dans la partie mémorielle et culturel
qui explore les oeuvres inspirées par
l'esclavagé sous le regard de plusieurs
artistes d'axel gauvin à daniel
vaxelaire d'emmanuel genvrin à françoise
guimbert un espace de parole est aussi
donnée aux associations de promotion de
la part africaine de notre île en ligne
également les indispensables sur l'
esclavage avec notamment son document 50
images de romo et deux expositions
le tout en accès libre et gratuit pour
ceux qui ont besoin d'aller à
l'essentiel
comme les écoles les médiathèques les
associations les communes en novembre un
colloque international a interrogé les
esclavages comme sujets d'histoire et
enjeux de mémoire en décembre ainsi que
deux conférences démarre avec un
spécialiste mondial de la question à la
bibliothèque départementale pour les
quatre courses pédestres dédié à cette
histoire des artistes et artisans d'art
ont créé des trophées de la liberté à la
rentrée universitaire prochaine
trois bourses de recherche seront
attribués par le département sur la
thématique de la traite de l'esclavagé
et de l'abolition
côté expos en 2019 sarda garriga qui
t'aura le quai branly pour revenir à la
réunion au musée léon dierx où se
rejouera la scène de la proclamation de
l'abolition des éditions et des guides
sont programmés la version 2 de regards
croisés sur l' esclavage et un guide des
sentiers du marronnage toujours en 2019
une campagne de fouilles se déroulera
sur les ruines de l'ancienne usine
sucrière de villèle réalisée par
l'institut national de recherches
archéologiques préventives
elle tentera de percer les secrets de
ces vestiges avant leur valorisation
dans les futurs aménagements du musée
au musée justement une présence sera
donnée aux esclaves grâce notamment à
trois sculptures trois frères esclaves
de nathalie plante poujol ban marot
nerfs de nathalie maillot et nelson
boyer et parce que c'est toute
l'histoire qu'il faut raconter ou bling
des bassins de geneviève jean jacques
dans le même esprit des centaines de
collégiens s'applique depuis des mois a
donné un visage à catiches ellie ou
césar des esclaves qui ont vécu à
villèle leur galerie de portraits sera
exposée aux musées comme le mémorial aux
esclaves restaurée qui sera réouvert au
public ce 20 décembre
si le chantier va durer plusieurs années
décevant décembre les jalons du futur
musée seront posées l'habitation des
bassins mettra en lumière et en scène
une page majeure de l'histoire de la
réunion trois objets symboliques le
kayamb le bob rpt et le rouleur
entreront dans la collection du musée de
villèle d'ailleurs c'est le cas yang qui
sera rouler symboliquement par firmin
viry pan célébrer la liberté ce 20
décembre à villèle et donner ainsi le
tempo de l'année commémorative mais pas
si tôt la balle perdue
[Musique]